just when I discovered the meaning of
life they changed one of my favorite
things about JavaScript is that the
status quo never seems to last very long
react angular and view have dominated
the mind share of developers over the
last few years
salt has been around for a while but
they just released version three last
week and my initial experience with it
has been very positive and that's mostly
because it empowers you to solve
problems with less code in the first
half of this video we'll cover the basic
concepts in spelt and in the process
you'll see why it's such an awesome tool
in the second half of the video we'll
build a real-time to-do list with spelt
and firebase from scratch if you're new
here like and subscribe and you can find
the full source code on fire ship IO now
before you jump into spelt I'd recommend
watching this talk from its creator rich
harris that's what really got me excited
to start learning spell 3 let's go ahead
and just jump right into things will run
npx dig it and then point to these felt
j s template this is the equivalent to
create react app or ng new go ahead and
open it up in vs code and run npm
install then you can run npm dev to
serve it locally and that should give
you this hello world on localhost 5000
the first thing you'll see is the roll
up config dot j s this is what bundles
your code and it's an alternative to web
pack personally i prefer to use roll-up
but you can also use webpack here if you
want and while we're talking about
bundling there's two things you should
know and that's that spelt supports
server-side rendering as well as native
web components or custom elements so
that's cool but so far this might just
look like another JavaScript framework
but if we go into the package.json we
can see that something's different here
what's missing is dependencies we only
have development dependencies and that's
because spelt is a compiler it generates
all of your code at Build time which
means it doesn't need to include the
framework itself as a hard dependency in
your JavaScript bundle another framework
that also does this is stencil j/s and I
feel like this approach makes a lot more
sense than the current status quo and
that's because you only need to compile
the JavaScript from the framework that
you actually need so you don't have any
extra bloat in your JavaScript bundle
what I'm doing right now is just
exporting our entire app as a string and
if we go to the bundled output you can
see that it's just a function that
returns a string so in theory this
should result in smaller bundle sizes or
at least bundles that are optimized for
the code that you actually use if you're
using tree shakable libraries that's
what makes felt fundamentally different
than the status quo but we've only just
hit the tip of the iceberg here it's
also unique in the way that it handles
reactivity if we go into the app
component we'll see a script up here at
the top that's where we keep our main
JavaScript logic and then we
a style tag all the styles will be
scoped to this component and another
cool thing about the compiler is that it
will automatically eliminate all of your
unused CSS styles from the CSS bundle
and then after that we have our markup
and spelt has its own templating syntax
for adding logic to your HTML this is a
similar approach to angular and view but
differs from react which uses JSX now
the difference with JSX is that you're
taking your HTML and putting it inside
of JavaScript and letting the JavaScript
handle the logic this can be a very
divisive topic and it's really just a
matter of opinion but I just find I'm
more productive by putting the logic at
the HTML like we do with angular view
and spelled now if we go up into the
script you'll notice I have export Latin
name using the export keyword in front
of a variable means that it can be
passed down from a parent component if
we leave the export keyword off it
basically means we have a private
variable that can only be used inside of
this component now the cool thing about
spelt is that it's reactive based on the
assignment of a variable we'll create a
variable here for a random number and
then create a function that can reassign
that variable so now that we have this
function we need to bind it to an event
in the Dom you can bind to events by
doing on colon click or on : whatever
Dom event you want to bind to this is
very similar to all of the frameworks we
passed in the function and it's going to
call that function with the event passed
as the argument so that's going to
change the random number and then we can
show it in the template by wrapping it
in braces now we have an app that reacts
to this randomize button whenever we
click it we get a new random number but
what happens if we need to compute a
different value from this random number
let's say if it rounds to 1 it'll be a
winner if it rounds to zero it'll be a
loser the simplest solution is just to
write that expression directly in the
template and spelt will rerun this logic
every time the reactive value changes
but this isn't going to scale very well
because we can't reuse this logic if we
want to show that same value somewhere
else in the template we'd have to
duplicate that code fortunately spelt
has a very cool trick up its sleeve for
computed values we'll define any
variable but instead of using let will
use this dollar sign colon syntax
believe it or not this is valid vanilla
JavaScript and it's basically just a way
to tell spelt to recalculate this value
when the app reacts now we can go back
into our template and simply reuse the
result computed value as many times as
we want
now speaking of reactivity another thing
we can do is bind to the attributes on
Dom elements for example if we want to
bind to the value attribute on a form
input we can do that with this bind
directive and
use our random variable if we start
typing in the form you'll see how the
value itself is recomputed every time we
type a new value now currently our
computed result is a string but let's go
ahead and change that to a number and
then we'll show an entirely different
template based on some conditional logic
the new computed value will give us a
number between one and a hundred and we
can show a template conditionally by
using this if syntax and we can also
throw in else if if we have multiple
conditions and then else for the default
value and then we'll just add some Dom
elements in between these conditions and
that will recompute the template every
time our random number changes so that's
pretty standard stuff but now I want to
show you something that you're not going
to find in other frameworks let's go
ahead and import fade and fly from spelt
transition these are directives that
will allow you to automatically compute
CSS animations based on the logic in
your template so if you want something
to fade in and fade out when it's added
or removed to the Dom you can just add
this transition fade directive and
everything will just happen
automatically but let's say we want our
poop emojis to fly in from the right and
then fly out to the left
normally this would take some careful
thought about your CSS animations or you
might use a JavaScript animation library
but in spelt we can use the directives
to keep the animation logic tied
directly to the Dom element that's being
animated and then we can add our own
properties to it to customize the way it
behaves and that gives us poop flying
all over the screen which is the effect
we're going for and there's even a
directive specifically for SVG graphics
that we'll draw the path along the shape
so that's really awesome stuff but
there's still a couple of other
fundamental things that I want to show
you before we get to the full demo
earlier I mentioned that spelt is
reactive based on assignment so if we
have an array and then we push new items
to the array we won't get any actual
changes in the Dom that's because we're
just mutating the array and we're not
actually reassigning the variable so if
you want the app to react to changes to
an array or to an object it's generally
a good idea to use the spread syntax
this code here will do the same thing as
a right push but it will also reassign
the variable causing the app to react
and update the Dom now when working at
the Rays you'll probably want to loop
over them and display some Dom elements
for each item we can do that by using
each which will give us access to both
the value and the index of each item in
the array when we build out our full
demo you'll also see that each loops
work with asynchronous values similar to
the async pipe and angular and speaking
of asynchronous values spelt has a
really cool way of handling promises I
have a helper function here that just
creates a delay
I'm defining our random value is a
promise that results to a random number
after that delay when working with
promises there's generally three things
that happen
first you're in some kind of loading
state waiting for the promise to resolve
then you get a value or maybe you get an
error and need to show some kind of
error message in spelt you can await a
promise directly in the template and
this will also handle things like race
conditions for you automatically the
first section is where you would put
your loading spinner while the promise
is being resolved then you show the
actual result or you catch the error and
show an error message and that provides
a very readable and intuitive way to
handle promises in my opinion it's
actually very similar to a future
builder and flutter if there's any
flutter developers watching at this
point now we're going to switch gears
into spelt stores which behave very
similar to rxjs observables and they can
be shared anywhere in the component tree
so you have a very easy mechanism for
sharing data anywhere in your app let's
go ahead and create a writable store and
it's very similar to a behavior subject
in rxjs at least in terms of its API
first we can pass it a default value and
then we can set the value directly by
calling set or we can call update to get
access to the current value and then
compute a new value in the stream which
we can do with this callback function
which gives us the current value then we
return the next value and if we just
want to listen to the value we just
subscribe to it but if you've worked
with observables then you know that you
need to manage your subscriptions
carefully otherwise you could end up
with memory leaks if we go back into our
component the first thing that we'll do
is import the random store that we just
created we could subscribe to that
directly in the JavaScript but then we
would have to dispose of it once this
component is destroyed that leads to a
lot of boilerplate and also a lot of
potential for error but notice how I
have this dollar sign in front of the
store value itself this will tell the
compiler to automatically subscribe to
the value and also manage the
subscription automatically and now we
can push new values to the stream from
any component anywhere in the app that
will solve a lot of your complex data
sharing situations but you can also just
pass props directly between a parent and
child component I went ahead and created
a new component called child and it's
just a dumb component that displays some
properties now we'll go back up to our
app component and pass some properties
down to this child let's imagine we have
this data object here that we pulled
from a database or something now we can
go and declare our child component and
just pass in each property one by one
but even after just three simple
properties it's starting to become kind
of hard to read but spelt has yet
another little piece of magic that will
make this code
much nicer you can simply send all of
your props down to the child using these
spread syntax so now that you know some
of the basic concepts in spelt I want to
put everything together into a full
working demo in just a few minutes we'll
be able to build this real-time to-do
list that also includes user
authentication and even some animation
once a user is logged in they'll be able
to fill out this form with some
information about the to do that'll be
saved to fire store and they can toggle
it complete or incomplete or delete it
and of course everything will stay
synched up with the backend database
we'll be using our Xfire for this demo
which you can install with the following
command the first thing we'll do is
create a file called firebase J s just
used to initialize firebase and you'll
need to use the credentials from your
own firebase project we'll be going
through this code very quickly so make
sure to follow along with the source
code on fire ship io
but basically the purpose of this file
is just to initialize the app and then
export auth and the fire stored database
so we can use them in other files from
there we'll go into the app component
and we just have a few small changes to
make here we'll import this login
component which will create next and
with spelt you'll notice that there's no
index.html that you can mess with so
instead what you can do is use this felt
colon head tag to add additional things
to the head of the document in this demo
I'm using the boma CSS framework just so
we have some better base styles to work
with after that we'll build our off
features so the user has a way to log in
I'm creating a profile component which
will just be a dumb presentational
component to show the users display name
photo URL and user ID and another cool
side note here is that svelt will
automatically warn you for accessibility
issues for example if we leave out the
alt attribute it's going to warn us to
add one you can also do this in ES lint
but it's nice to just have this stuff
working right out of the gate after that
we can create the logging component
which is the smart component that does
the actual interaction with firebase now
the interesting thing about spelt is
that the shape of the stores are similar
to the shape of rxjs observables so that
means we can use some of that syntactic
sugar on rxjs observables in addition to
spelt stores currently I'm grabbing the
off-state observable from our Xfire and
just subscribing to it manually but
we'll refactor this in a minute and I'll
also define a function here to trigger
the pop-up that will allow the user to
log in with Google and that will cause
the value of the AA state observable to
change now we can go down to the
template and create an if-else statement
and if we have a user logged in we'll go
ahead and display that user profile
component and of course use that spread
syntax to pass the props down and if the
user is not logged in we'll just
a button that can trigger that login
function at this point we have a fully
working off system but we can actually
refactor this a little bit to use some
of spells built-in syntactic sugar this
time we'll define the user as the
observable itself and then we'll just go
ahead and use that dollar sign syntax to
unwrap the observable directly in the
template that'll work inside the if
condition and also works inside these
spread syntax and now we have a login
component that will manage our
subscription automatically with almost
no boilerplate now it's time to move on
to the to-do list each of the individual
to-do items will be represented by this
dumb component called to-do item but
instead of just displaying data it's
also going to emit custom events up to
the parent component so this is a way to
pass data from a child component back up
to the parent and in this case we're
doing that so we can tell the parent
component when to remove the item from
the database or when to update the
status in the database spelt has a thing
called an event dispatcher which will
create a custom event in the Dom for you
in this case when we want to remove an
item will dispatch an event called
remove with that items ID in the
database and then we'll do a similar
thing to talk about the status of it
to-do item but this time we'll pass the
ID as well as the new status that the
item should change to now I'm defining a
CSS class that will show when an item is
complete and I'm going to make sure that
that class name is the same of the
property that toggles that class which
is the boolean value of complete on this
component and we might as well just add
a transition to this item when it's
created so it kind of slides in from the
right and we can easily do that by
simply using spell its transition
directive from there we can go ahead and
add the text inside the list item and
when it's complete we want to show that
CSS class spelt has a built in class
directive which we can use like this by
pointing it to the complete property but
if the CSS class and the property both
share the same name which they do in
this case we can actually make this even
more concise like so now the last thing
we'll do in this component is create our
buttons that will dispatch the custom
events we have three different buttons
here two of those are used to toggle the
status and the other one is used to
remove the item and now we're ready to
move on to the final component of this
app which is the to-do list I'm not
going to talk too much about the
firebase code basically we're just
making a reference to the collection in
the database and then making a query for
all of the to-do items that are
associated with the logged in users user
ID then we're going to use the
collection data function from our Xfire
which takes that query and converts it
to an observable of the document data
but in order to work with an each loop
and
belt will also want to pipe and start
with and that will guarantee that the
observable always has a synchronous
array to start with from there we'll
define the update status method which
will take the custom event that's being
emitted by the child component and use
it to make an update to the firestore
database and then we'll do the same
basic thing to handle the remove event
now if we go down to the template we'll
set up an each loop and notice that I
put a dollar sign in front of the two
dues observable this will unwrap The
Observer will automatically manage the
subscription and then react to any new
changes whether they happen client-side
or on the server and then we can pass
our props down to the to-do item
component and then we can also listen to
the custom events that we defined on
that component as well so instead of
just doing a simple on click event here
we're doing on remove and on toggle
again those are custom events defined in
the child component and then the very
last thing we'll do is set up a form
input using the bind value directive and
then set up a button that will add that
item to the database when clicked and
that's all there is to it we now have a
reactive real-time to-do app overall
I've been super impressed with spelt the
only thing that I think is missing at
this point is typescript support but
from what I understand there should be
typescript support in the near future I
think what impresses me the most about
spelt is that the abstractions are
really well-thought-out but they don't
take you too far away from the Nilla
javascript or native dom api's I'm gonna
go ahead and wrap things up there let me
know what you think about spelt in the
comments thanks for watching and I will
talk to you soon
[Music]